tout est
mais les gars y'a pas de raison cette
production
[Musique]
heureux de vous accueillir dans notre
nouveau centre de jeunes et de détox ou
la vache est un fondu comme beurre au
soleil je leur dit combien on peut
s'embrasser avant de passer à la pesée
j'ai le trac je rappelle par sa quête
les gros c'est pas ce qui manque
tiré du vomi ça va nettoyer mais un test
de l'eau de l'aquarium là je suis là
pour faire un jeu préféré me taper un
jeune de 25 ans
mais vont passer du bon temps ensemble
non on est là pour maigrir si je veux
passer du bon temps je me fais un
plateau de fromages on peut vivre sans a
toujours dans un rapport de séduction
quand même avec grave alors preuve
chômage à 5 heures à quoi ça sert d'être
mince ça va pas empêcher carlos de me
quitter danton call le problème c'est
peut-être pas le poids
carlos m'a quittée pour un homme et si
je veux le récupérer faut que je
redevienne grosse saucisse j'arrive à
l'aller 2 est ce que tu crois que ça
peut redémarrer un carlos quand tu as
fait ton coming out c'est très rare que
tu fasses ton coming back
s'imposer
vous vous êtes et les hollies
maigrir il faut de la volonté mois la
surface je comprends le mot vous montez
c'est dans la phrase plus affrontés en
fait faut enlever ses complexes avant
normes et ses culottes
ces éléments ce qui sont vouloir non en
tout cas la merkel elle dirige
l'allemagne et la visage qui tombe oh la
la c'est magnifique c'est des framboises
y voit si tu fumes les feuilles
peut-être que tu verras des framboises
et
à
accompli
ouais deux originaux là j'ai bien pris